[Plane engine sounds]
>>Ian: Hello everyone welcome to the triumphant
return of--
>>Ian and Dan: The Friday Game Review!
>>Dan: I didn't say game.
>>Ian: That was unrehearsed.
>>Dan: Yeah. You can tell.
>>Ian: I am Ian Ni-Lewis and as always with
me he is...
>>Dan: Dan Galpin and today I am actually
wearing the cheese head.
>>Ian: It's about time. Dan Galpin. I don't
know if I've really made the is clear because
we make fun of Dan a lot on this
show.[Dan Laughs] Dan walks among mortals
as a coding slash developer relations god,
someone who can only be expressed
in, with a headgear--
>>Dan: I just thought it was the fact that
I am generally cheesy where ever I go.
>>Ian: Actually what it is is, Dan is so good
at what he does, that he basically just lifts
a middle finger to the world and
it's silly fashion requirements.
>>Dan: Right, exactly. [Chuckles]
>>Ian: Well, check that out. Our producer,
Ray Taylor, now has two cameras to work with.
Camera One! Camera Two!
>>Dan: Oooo, nice, that's exciting.
>>Ian: Unfortunately, camera two is apparently
not lit at all.
>>Dan: No, it's not.
>>Ian: We'll work on that.
>>Dan: We'll have to get light actually bouncing
off of us toward camera two, although realistically,
that's not my best
angle.
>>Ian: Really?
>>Dan: It’s not.
>>Ian: You have a good angle?
>>Dan: No, but, uh, I have ones that are worse
than others.
>>Ian: Okay. Joining us as well is the mystery
beer.
>>Dan: Yeah. I've been taunted by the mystery
beer for several hours now so
>>Ian: Yep.
>>Dan: So, now I'm going to try this--
>>Ian: It actually came in this wrapper, although
I turned it inside out so you wouldn't be
able to tell what it is.
>>Dan: Oh I see.
>>Ian: Okay, ready?
>>Dan: So this is it.
>>Ian: Bottoms up!
[long pause]
>>Dan:Hmm.
>>Ian: That's pretty hoppy.
>>Dan: That’s pretty significantly bitter.
I like it.
>>Ian: Ah, indeed. That is, uh, so this is
another from our friends at McKellar.
|
>>Dan: Oh, fantastic. Wow! I think--
>>Ian: Yes, the Mackellar
>>Dan and Ian: One thousand IBU.
>>Ian: And just to put that into context,
I think most IPA's top out at around a couple
of hundred.
>>Dan: Yeah. Actually, you know, it’s quite
good. I think that--
>>Ian: It's powerful. I think you reach a
point of bitterness where you just can't get
any bitterer.
>>Dan: Yeah, basically we spent the last six
months or so building up a tolerance to all
things bitter here, and uh--
>>Ian: That's true.
>>Dan: Yeah, and it's, uh.
>>Ian: Wait, I've been working with you for
a year.
[Dan laughs]
>>Dan: That's true. But that's me building
up a tolerance for all things bitter.
>>Ian: Gotcha.
>>Dan: All right.
>>Ian: All right. So, let's get right on to
the games. We've got some really interesting
things today. We've got a few games
that came off of the moderator that we're
going to look at.
>>Dan: Thanks for your voting.
>>Ian: Yeah, thank you very much for voting.
Sorry to everyone whose games were not chosen.
There were some comments today
on the Friday Review Google plus page talking
about why certain things were or were not
voted in. So I just wanted to clear
that up. The reason why something will get
chosen is, "a", because you vote it up, and
"b", because we want to talk about
it. Typically, Ray Taylor and I will sit down
and look at the top ten apps and the top ten
games, and Ray-To will pick some
number of apps from that of which he'll cover
maybe three. [Dan chuckles] And then Dan and
I will sit down and look at the
games, look at the top ten, and choose usually
the top six. We generally try to choose just
the top voted games,
but we don't always, and usually it's because
one of the top voted games is one we just
don't have much to say about. I'm
Particularly looking at you, X-Bugs dude,
we talked about your thing twice man, so quit
it with the complaining because
we're not going to talk about it again. It's
a good game; we did actually nominate it,
for uh, yeah.
>>Dan: We did.
>>Ian: A lot of times a nomination will take
four to five weeks to go through, and the
reason is, merchandizing has a whole
pile of apps that could be featured, and then
they choose the ones that they think are going
to be best for that particular
week.
>>Dan: As with X-Bugs itself, I vaguely remember
some comment that squashing bugs was not as
fun as they thought it would
be, you know? That just might be their opinion,
I thought that squashing bugs was quite a
lot of fun.
>>Ian: I thought it was endless fun.
>>Dan: I wouldn't go that far.
>>Ian: For the whole family.
[Dan laughs]
>>Dan: It was something that small children
would appreciate and it's a lot nicer than
having them squash real bugs, so you
know, in general.
>>Ian: It's a bug squashing simulator, they're
going to go out and squash bugs all weekend
long as soon as they get away
from the computer.
>>Dan: They're mutant bugs. Now we've talked
about the game.
>>Ian: That's a good point.
>>Dan: All right.
>>Ian: Oooooo.
>>Dan: All right, so we're also going to talk
about some games that weren't actually nominated
because Ian and I had
something miraculous happen in the last week.
>>Ian: Yes!
>>Dan: we actually got a few days off, following--
>>Ian: Yes, and boy do I regret it, the first
moment I open up my email inbox,
>>Dan: So we actually had some time to play
games that were not on the moderator list.
And so we want to talk about some of
the games we've been playing, some of them
last week and some of them throughout the
last couple of months and put them
through the same kind of critical filter as
we put everything else on the Friday Game
Review through. And, uh, and also we
want to talk a little bit about some of the
things that have gone on in the last few weeks,
one of course is, today we are
shipping Nexus 7 devices, which is awesome.
>>Ian: No way! Today?
>>Dan: Yeah. Today.
>>Ian: Really? And this is a surprise to me
because none of us knew actually. A lot of
people are like, "Why is Google so
secretive? Why won't they say when they're
shipping things?" Because we don't know.
>>Dan: Yeah, pretty much.
>>Ian: I mean, I'm sure somebody knows. We
don't.
>>Dan: We posted it, the only reason I know
is that we posted it on a Google Plus page,
and--
>>Ian: There you go!
>>Dan: And I'm like all right! I guess we're
shipping devices, how cool.
>>Ian: Seriously, if you and I ever get fired,
we'll probably find out about from the public--like
through a blog or
something.
>>Dan: I expect.
>>Ian: Because that's how we find out everything.
[Laughter]
>>Dan: I'm like, okay I guess I should pack
up my desk.
>>Ian: Exactly.
>>Dan: All right so.
>>Ian: All right, so Nexus 7. Let's bring
that bad boy up. This is an awesome game machine,
and I'll tell you why.
First, it's got the Tegra 3 inside,
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: so very similar to our previous standby
which is the ASUS Transformer Prime, actually
we're still going to use the
ASUS Transformer Prime on the show, and the
reason is it has one of the best HDMI output
implementations that we've ever
seen.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
>>Ian: Whereas the Nexus 7 stock does not
come with an HDMI output at all. But, I'm
playing games on this,
and I'll tell you why. Because it is just
as fast--
>>Dan: Mmm Hmm.
>>Ian: and it's easier to hold. The truth
is, having a, in fact if Ray-To would go to
camera two for a second, when you have
the ability to just hold it in your hands
like this, compared to, right, the--
>>Dan: The Docking especially--
>>Ian: Yeah, you might want to take the dock
off.
>>Dan: The dock is so cool.
>>Ian: Well, all right, whatever.
>>Dan: Okay, all right.
>>Ian: For some definition of cool, anyway,
the way you hold it in your hands like this,
it's just really easy. I can play
accelerometer games, I can play duel stick
games, and I never get tired of holding it,
and I never feel like I have to
stretch my thumbs to reach elements of the
interface, but at the same time, I never feel
like I'm squinting because it's so
much bigger than a phone.
>>Dan: Yeah, it's an awesome game playing
device, and it's where I've been doing all
of the gaming that I don't do on Galaxy
Nexus these days, and, uh,
>>Ian: Yep.
>>Dan: And you know there are, I'm just excited
for more game developers to get their hands
on it. I think it's fantastic,
like we finally have a development platform
that anyone can go and buy, one of the latest
version of android, that
hopefully will be available at some point
to everyone around the world, but today it's
available to a lot of people so
that's really cool.
>>Ian: Yeah, and at a very good price point
too.
>>Dan: Yeah, and Jay is awesome, and that,
we're not actually talking about , we're talking
about this, but we're really
not trying to pimp this as a sales pitch.
Actually just really excited.
>>Ian: That's true, we're just really excited
about it.
>>Dan: I just want to make it really clear
that this is not our "This is the official
Nexus 7 commercial segment of the
Friday Game Review." This is because we frickin'
love playing games on this device.
>>Ian: Oh yeah.
>>Dan: And that's what it comes down to. And
you know, part--
>>Ian: Here's the thing, Jay, Jelly Bean..
>>Dan: Jelly Bean, yeah.
>>Ian: Oh my God.
>>Dan: Project Butter is awesome, and actually
>>Ian: Yeah, so--
>>Dan: Being able to actually synch the Vsynch
in your games is awesome. Everyone should
start doing it. It's really really cool and
we may even cover that someday, I don't know.
Maybe in another forum.
>>Ian: Yeah yeah, We've got some really pretty
good talks about that. Um, in general, the
improvements that were made in
Jelly Bean, will make your user experience
totally smooth. You will feel like you bought
a new device, okay. I put it on my
Galaxy Nexus, and I felt like I had just gotten
a new phone. I think it's finally gotten to
be, you know, what I would
consider, world class. Because I think we
can admit that Gingerbread and even ICS were
janke compared to what we really
wanted from the hardware, what the hardware
was capable of.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: We fixed all of that.
>>Dan: Actually we've gone beyond what the
hardware is capable of right now. [Unintelligible
word] In all seriousness, what's
cool about Jay for gamers is that our touch
response has gone from two to three frames
worth of delay to one frame fixed
delay which is amazing and--
>>Ian: We've actually seen significant performance
improvement in some games just for running
on Jelly Bean and the
interesting thing is--
>>together: We have NO idea why!
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: It's a complete mystery to us. We're
gonna figure it out one day.
>>Dan: This is the ultimate Temple Run machine,
I can tell you this.
>>Ian: That's right, Temple Run Brave got
ten or fifteen percent, or something like
that?
>>Dan: It was insane.
>>Ian: It was bizarre.
>>Dan: Yeah, it--
>>Ian: Is that a Unity game?
>>Dan: Yeah, it's a Unity game.
>>Ian: Did we see it that on any other Unity
titles?
>>Dan: I don't know. I don't really pay attention.
>>Ian: You were more playing Temple Run Brave,
nice.
>>Dan: That's the best part about it, is that
your gestures just get recognized just that
much better, it's just, its'
awesome. I'm really excited, I can't wait
to hear what you guys thing of it when you
get your hands on it and, uh, and let's
go on to some games!
>>Ian: Yeah, let's do that. So, yeah, this
is a very special episode of the Friday Game
Review, and I'm pretty sure when I
posted that, at least some people that grew
up in the 70's and 80's thought that it was
going to be about us kicking our
drug habits.
>>Dan: Hmph.
>>Ian: And it's not. Those habits are very
valuable to us.
>>Dan: Absolutely.
>>Ian: But, let's go ahead and take a look
at some of the games. Why don't we start with
one of the games that you've been
playing.
>>Dan: All right, not to be completely cliché
here, but I've been playing a lot of Dead
Trigger and this is Dead Trigger and
I'm actually getting wiped right now, running
here on the Transformer Prime. And this is
not my real game, I will point out
that I'm like to day seventy right now in
real life, and I think I'm on day five or
something like that. What's great about
Dead Trigger is the way to do a high quality
three title for mobile. They've been very
clever in the way they actually
reuse a relatively small number of environments
to do a whole variety of different missions,
and they've managed to fit the
game into about a hundred megabytes, which
is great. Now, however--
>>Ian: And I love how they have an ad for
Shattergun.
>>Dan: They do.
>>Ian: That rocks.
>>Dan: But here's the one problem with that
ad, I mean seriously?
[Laughter]
So one thing, if you're going to do something
cool enough, like have an ad for your other
game. Dude! Show the people the
stuff.
>>Ian: Show it some love, man.
>>Dan: Show it some love.
>>Ian: Come on you guys.
>>Dan: That's one thing. Another thing is
back button support. I'm hitting the back
button right now and you notice nothin'
is happening.
>>Ian: No back button.
>>Dan: Yeah, it's just, you know.
>>Ian: Ouch.
>>Dan: Yeah, it's like they never watch this
show. You know, which is amazing, but--
>>Ian: We get it. You're awesome, you're from
Europe, you can do things differently, but
not the fricken' back button.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: You do not mess with that pal.
[Dan laughs]
>>Dan: So that's one thing, another thing
about the game is, it actually does have a
limited back button support on the main
page when you actually get back to it, it's
like, eek, mission failed.
[nonsense sounds]
>>Dan: It's the dreaded quit application dialog.
>>Ian: And what it really comes down to is
this is a great game, you know, you should
all try it out, you know play it,
you're going to have a lot of fun with it,
but it will not be a featured app in Google
Play.
>>Dan: Until they fix some of these things,
yeah.
>>Ian: Yeah, because the Google Play Q&A team
is just going to look at this and laugh. Of
course, we're going to nominate,
we're going to work with these guys, because
we think they're awesome, we think that it
should be featured in Google Play.
>>Dan: Um hmm.
>>Ian: But they're going to have to fix this
stuff before it gets featured.
>>Dan: Totally. And the game really is awesome.
The other thing that people, and I will say
a lot of people have been
commenting on Google Play that "Hey, this
is a ninety-nine cent game and it expects
me to buy stuff."
>>Ian: Oh, it's "pay-me-um".
>>Dan: And actually, the reality of the game
is, you can grunt your way through this game
without buying anything, as far as
I can tell. Maybe at some point.
>>Ian: Plus, you know what?
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: Get over yourselves.
>>Dan: Yeah, I know.
>>Ian: This is a fifteen dollar game. This
would have sold for fifteen bucks on Xbox
Live and you know it.
>>Dan: Yeah, this is--
>>Ian: Ninety-nine cents is pretty good deal.
>>Dan: It's a really good deal. And to be
honest, I am not on day seventy something
of the game, and I still only paid the
ninety-nine cents, and part of the reason
I did that was I wanted to see could I actually
get through the entire game with
ninety-nine cents? We still don't really know
if that's true, but as the weeks go by, I'll
try to update you guys.
>>Ian: I've been wondering Dan, for you, just
in terms of the way you perceive things--
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: How many hours are in a day?
>>Dan: Uh, twenty-six. So uh.
>>Ian: That answers my question.
>>Dan: Actually, there's only four hours for
sleep, is what it really comes down to, so--
>>Ian: Wow.
>>Dan: Well, you know, I know that since you've
had a child, four hours of sleep is actually
a luxury, so in any case,
I'll continue reporting back, and also I hope
to come back to this came when they fix some
of these things because it is
awesome! So that is Dead Trigger. Now, other
games that we are playing, now this game is
not on the main screen here because
it was already installed, um, so.
>>Ian: Oh, mine, yes. I'm going to take this
out of the thing here.
>>Dan: Okay.
>>Ian: Um, okay, Radiant Defense is, every
year or two, and there comes a game I have
to finish. I almost never finish a
game.
>>Dan: mmm hmm
>>Ian: And in this particular case, it was
Radiant Defense. I think the last game--
>>Dan: Have you actually finished it now?
>>Ian: I have finally finished it. I have
three starred every level.
>> Dan: Nice!
>>Ian: I love that tower defense games. I
think tower defense games are great. This
one in particular really really caught
my eye. So, it was free to download.
>>Unknown male speaker: Before you go in to
it, I think you disconnected the HDMI cable.
>>Together: Oh!
>>Ian: How's that?
>>Unknown male speaker: That's better.
>>Ian: Wonderful.
>>Dan: You must be very cautious that these
mini HDMI cables, MicroAge HDMI cables.
>>Ian: Yeah yeah. What's really, really interesting
about this game is that unlike the, so, as
go ahead and get past the
sort of cheesy, humorous sections here. They
actually are pretty funny , um,
>>Dan: The humor is good, yeah.
>>Ian: Well, it's right up at like the Captain
Underpants level.
>>Dan: Exactly, just where we like it.
>>Ian: Just where we like it. Okay. So like
many tower defense games, enemies will come
on a path, what makes this one
interesting is that you will set the path
by building blocks. Now a lot of games will
let you set the path, you know alter
the path by building towers. But in this case,
you can't build towers on the path. You have
to build towers on these
existing black squares, but you also get a
certain number of these black squares that
the blocks to set yourself. So if I set up
these
modules, I can actually lengthen or alter
the path this turns out to be one of the major--
>>Dan: Innovations.
>>Ian: Innovations, well, it turns out to
be one of the major strategies that you have
to think about.
>>Dan: Oh, okay.
>>Ian: There's a lot of levels where you're
absolutely hopeless unless you've built the
correct path. But if you have built
a path that makes sense, you know for instance,
you've got aliens coming at you from two different
areas, you need to build
a path so that one of them takes so long that
you get it second rather than getting both
of them at the same time.
>>Dan: Right, exactly.
>> Ian: And the other innovation, the other
thing that I think is really interesting,
is that towers miss. The towers
actually have aim, and they rotate around
at a fixed speed. So, sometimes, you're seeing
it right now, every now and then
one of those bullets will just miss one of
the enemies, so you have to be a really careful
about your tower placement,
because you don't want to make it so that
they have to rotate around really quick. You
don't want to make it so the shots
are hard, for instance, if you place a tower
where the aliens are coming past it, then
it's going to be harder for it to
make the shots because they're coming faster,
whereas, if you place a tower when enemies
are coming towards it, it's a lot
easier to make the shot.
>>Dan: I love the graphics style of this game.
>>Ian: The style is great.
>>Dan: Hexage just does it with all our games,
but Radiant Defense is the pinnacle of what
they've done with this style.
I think is brilliant and you know you immediately
look at one of their games, and you immediately
say,"Oh that's Hexage
game." That's just it. So I hope that's how
it's pronounced.
>>Ian: Hecks-AH-gay?
>>Dan: Hecks-AH-gay. That's right it could
be. [laughter]
>>Unknown male speaker: You know they're a
Japanese Company right?
>>Ian: Right, there you go.
>>Dan: They build in the U.K. I believe so,
we're going for Hexage.
>>Ian: So the graphics are great, they've
got this really cute cartoon-y style but it's
not too cute.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: All of the enemies and the weapons
are really well rendered. They all have their
own behaviors that keep you engaged,
but on top of that they, they just have a
really deep strategy, and of really interesting
monetization model. So this is
one of those games where you buy upgrade packs
and I have to admit I bought all the upgrade
packs so when I say I three
starred it, I did three star it I had to buy
all the upgrade packs. Let me show you what
they've got.
>>Dan: You can even get the, yeah yeah.
>>Ian: So, basically it was say that I want
this, the best weapon in the game by far is
the ballistic missile, the Seraphim
Missile launcher. Reason it's such a great
weapon is because the,uh, they're seeking.
>>Dan: Oh, okay.
>>Ian: So if they miss, they'll come around
again.
>>Dan: Isn't Seraphim like the name of the
Pharisees or something? I don't know.
>>Ian: You're thinking of Sadducees, Seraphim
were they were just like Cherubim.
>>Dan: That's it. Right.
>>Ian: They were Kabbalistic angels.
>>Dan: That's right, that's why they were
called Kabbalistic. I was just curious if
there was some mythological reference
there that I was missing here.
>>Ian: I think we've both missed it.
>>Dan: Okay.
>>Ian: So, if I want to unlock this, they're
going to sell me the explosive pack, and I
don't know, it's like a dollar
ninety-nine or so. Or you can get the science
pack.
>>Dan: Ooooo.
>>Ian: Which gives you power blades, which
are awesome because you know how there is
always like one enemy that gets away
from you and he's got like one hit point left,
but he still kills you? Well, you put a power
blade in front of your base,
and he runs into it and "boom."
>>Dan: Awesome, awesome.
>>Ian: Yeah, incredible stuff. Just really
fun stuff. The other thing that I love about
it, um, I think you do have to buy
it, if I remember, I think it's one of these.
Oh, maybe not, maybe not. I think it's actually
in there to begin with. They
have a specific type of tower that doesn't
do any damage, but if an enemy dies near it,
it doubles your money.
>>Dan: NICE! I like that.
>>Ian: So, you get into these really interesting
strategies, where you're not just trying to
kill all the aliens, you’re
trying to kill them in the right place so
you can get the most money and the way they
score is, so like many games that I
enjoy an interest bonus between rounds, which
gives you an incentive to spend the least
money possible, now they cap that at
five hundred dollars, so if you get more than
five hundred, you're not going to get any
more interest, which is, eh. You
know.
>>Dan: Makes sense.
>>Ian: Yeah. But then what they do for your
score is they take all the enemies that you
killed and all the money you have
left and they have a multiplication factor.
So if you want to get a HUGE high score on
this game, which I haven't. I think
the top ten high scores are all about twenty
million, I think, three starring every level,
I might have broken two million.
>>Dan: Wow, so, so the moral of this story
is that this game monetized well enough that
Ian went and bought everything in
the game, so it's probably one that--
>>Ian: With my own money, not my Google credit
card.
>>Dan: Yes, this is probably one,
>>Ian: Good deal.
>>Dan: This is probably one that is probably
worth looking at if you're studying what's
a decent story. Of course, Ian may
not reflect everyone's taste but this game
is truly awesome.
>>Ian: Not at all. I am very different. It's
a lot of fun, and not only did it give me
a reason to buy, did you notice how
good their merchandising is?
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: They're not just saying, it's not a
stupid little list of things that you can
buy that's dull, and boring, it's--
>>Dan: They sell it to you, they're mock marketing
it within the game to me as the player of
the game, which is awesome--
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan: You know, this is NOT the place to
cut corners, in a game, when you're actually
like getting to the monetary phase.
>>Ian: Right. It's not like, you know, four
thousand radiant bucks or something like that.
You know that--
>>Dan: This is what you're getting.
>>Ian: This is what you get, but they've put
some nice graphics, they've given them creative
names that make me think, "Oh
yeah, I want that pack.." And even just saying
it's a pack.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: It's pretty cool.
>>Dan: For people who feel nickeled and dimed
by these games, this is a great strategy.
I think, actually, even if you are
selling this things individually, I think
the idea of selling them in packs is really
appealing.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan: Especially, what I really want Shadow
Gun to do actually is have an upgrade that
turns, that doubles the amount of
coins you get for everything in the game and
turns everything that you had to buy with
gold, which is the slow currency that
you basically don't get during the game into
something you could buy with coins. Basically,
unlocking the entire game
>>Ian: Exactly
>>Dan: into something you can just grind through
for like seven or eight dollars. Basically--
>>Ian: Right, right. I think this is actually
a nine or ten dollar game, which absolutely
is in line with the enjoyment that
I got out of it. I had a lot of fun. Could
have spent nothing, and still had a lot of
fun, but getting each pack really
increased my enjoyment.
>>Dan: Exactly, exactly.
>>Ian: Here's a question for you, by the way
about pricing. Would you rather get something
that is fifty percent off or
something were you get fifty percent more
free?
>>Dan: You know, usually, that's an interesting
question. I want both.
[Laughter]
>>Ian: And because you're Dan Galpin, you'll
probably get it, but let's pretend you're
me.
>>Dan:No, no. I think honestly fifty percent
more for free makes a lot of sense when it
comes to monetization in the game.
There are only a certain number of people
who are going to monetize, and if you can
make those users feel like they’re getting
value for their money and make them spend
a little bit more, my suspicion is that you're
going to monetize better.
>>Ian: So here's the thing, I was just reading
this in The Economist this morning, because
that's what I read when I brush
my teeth in the morning.
>>Dan: Right.
>>Ian: They had an article that said, they
did some studies on this, people would rather
get fifty percent more free than
get fifty percent of,
>>Dan: There you are.
>>Ian: even though, let's do the math,
>>Dan: They're spending more money.
>>Ian: fifty percent more free is thirty-three
percent off the price.
>>Dan: Mmm hmm.
>>Ian: So, just an interesting thing. But
definitely, people like to feel like they
are getting a better deal.
>>Dan: And I think that's the key thing. We're
working with Wind Up Knight, beginning of
the game, he pops up this dialog
and says, "BOOM! You can unlock the entire
game for the one time only price of blah."
And right after, I think you're after
the second level or something like that, and
it was his most popular purchase in the game
with people. One, he demonstrated
value; two, they already understood what they
were getting in terms of game play, and it
was so awesome, once you could
unlock the entire game, to not have to worry
about that, then you could just spend your
money on all the really cool
upgrades in the game, and it was very cool,
so I--
>>Ian: You know what is absolutely the biggest
draw monetization-wise? You know, everybody
should do this, this is what
we've discovered over and over again, the
biggest draw is something that is time limited.
>>Dan: MMM Hmm.
>>Ian: Where I can spend my money, I spend
my money on things that I truly enjoy, but
there are times when I have spent
more money than I was going to, for instance,
I bought platinum packs of cards on Big Win
Hockey. Really enjoyed that. Still
need to call those guys and ask them why my
team doesn't work anymore. Maybe because I
spent too much money on it, I don't
know.
>>Dan: The game simply was not intended for
a gamer of your caliber.
>>Ian: That's probably it.
>>Dan: And your wallet size.
>>Ian: Nah, oh yeah yeah.
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Ian: That's it. Anyway, If you see me on
Big Win Hockey, I will kick your ass. Why?
I have money.
>>Dan: Mmm hmm.
>>Ian: Not that much money, but probably,
ya know.
>>Dan: More money than most people want to
spend on virtual cards.
>>Ian: Let's put this in real terms. I'm stupid
with my money.
[Laughter]
>>Ian: Anyway, the point is that the platinum
cards were on sale, they were fifty percent
off for a week. And I have no idea
whether that's, whether they even stopped
that after a week, but it got me.
>> Dan: I, and actually time limited offers
are great. Not only that, people do one of
two things, one is to have an item
that is only available during that period,
period, during that time, in general, and
the second thing is to have an offer
or a sale that is only available for that
time period. Those are both great. Also, activities,
tournaments, anything you can
do to make the game more alive will get people,
I guess. You know what it actually was, I'm
wearing this cheese head, and so
you had to make fun of yourself this time
because I've basically got it all,
>>Ian: Basically, once you have the cheese
head, you're everything that I ever wanted
you to be. I have no further criticism.
[Laughter]
>>Dan: That's right. I've got the beard, I've
got the cheese head, we're all good.
>>Ian: Yup.
>>Dan: So let's go on to our next game.
>>Ian: Thank God you didn't wear the cheese
head without a beard, that would have been
disgusting.
>>Dan: Yeah, I know. I know. All right, so
we actually do have a--
>>Ian: So, you've been, well, you've been
playing one other game.
>>Dan: I have.
>>Ian: But we should probably get to the real.
>>Dan: Let's get to the real games.
>>Ian: Should we do Tiny Hawk?
>>Dan: Let's do Tiny Hawk.
>>Ian: Because I'll tell you this, I thought,
this is either a game about a little bitty
bird, or it's going to be about
skating and that's awesome. Thank God it’s
about skateboarding! Rock ON!
>>Dan: Yeah. This is a game that's about skateboarding
and, honestly, it's fun. It does have some
weird glitches,
occasionally like you just saw there. But
basically your job is to play Tiny Hawk here.
It's 8-bit retro style, it's really
retro style. It's not, you get--
>>Ian: The frame rate alone is much higher
than you get--
>>Dan:Yeah, in most retro games. Basically
you can do two things. You can jump, and you
can go down. And that's, the
goal is to get to the end and try to collect
all the cans of whatever those are. Um and--
>>Ian: What are those?
>>Dan: They're cans of random soft drink,
I think, of some sort.
>>Ian: Okay. Sort of energy beverage maybe?
>>Dan: It looks like it. I don't know, but,
and sometimes it's actually really hard to
jump. You have to kind of figure
out, and you can't really change your direction.
So it is sort of like this combination, endless
runner slash with this
skateboarding paradigm.
>>Ian: But you can bounce off the walls, that's
how you got there.
>>Dan: Exactly. You bounce off walls.
>>Ian: Nice, nice.
>>Ray-To: The HDMI is--
>>Dan: Oh, the HDMI, yeah. It's a little,
I'm going to put this back into its stand
>>Ian: Is that going to help, is that really
going to help?
>>Dan: Because I'm less likely, I won't pick
it up and I'm less likely to jostle it.
>>Ian: Can we just switch to camera two for
just a second? 'Cause I just want to mention
that this looks totally dorky.
Go ahead. Play the game.
>> Dan: Thanks.
>>Ian: Play it. Play it. Play it so.
>>Dan: So.
>>Ian: How dorky is that?
>>Dan: My dork Fu is strong.
>>Ian: Okay, all right.
>>Dan: All right, so does anyone, does anyone
understand that the dork Fu is strong reference?
I don't know. All right.
>>Ian: Whoa, you have a picture in picture
for camera two?
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: When did you make that? While you were
screwing around over here?
>>Ray-To: Pretty much, yeah.
>>Ian: Ray-To, you are so much better at this
stuff than I am. I don't know why.
>>Ray-To: It helps with job security.
>>Ian: Yeah, exactly. Well you do have a win
in seven.
[Laughter]
>>Dan: OH, is that what it's being called
these days?
>>Ian: Oh you missed that whole discussion.
>>Dan: I did.
>>Ian: It was great.
[Laughter]
>>Ian: We’ll stop with the inside jokes
now. Okay. So, Tiny Hawk verdict, what did
they do wrong?
>>Dan: I actually have not found anything
significant that they do wrong. The game does
the correct thing with the back key,
the game does the correct thing with audio.
Um, yeah.
>>Ian: Right on you guys.
>>Dan: So as far as the game itself can be
a little frustrating. Um, it is a native game,
I don't see why it has to be
anything other than my suspicion is..
>>Ian: Native game you mean?
>>Dan: NDK game. It's an NDK game.
>>Ian: It's a Marmalade game right?
>>Dan: It's a Marmalade game, exactly. But,
I mean, for the most part, they're doing the
right thing. I would say, you know,
this is, the only thing, if there was anything,
like it even allowed you to continue the thing
by hitting the continue
button. Like, they've really understood the
flow, and the way it should be. If there's
anything if I had to nitpick,
this looks like a dialog, and I might expect
hitting the back key actually gets rid of
it, rather than backs out, but it’s--
>>Ian: But if they say our pocket GDC, you
know what they're probably thinking is we
have options, and then in our pocket
IO, we changed that and said, you know what,
that other option wasn't very good, so.
>>Dan: Yeah, yeah.
>>Ian: But anyway.
>>Dan: But, in general, I actually think the
fact that you can just immediately continue
like that is awesome.
>>Ian: Yeah. I'm really impressed, so we're
gonna go ahead and nominate this.
>>Dan: Yeah, absolutely.
>>Ian: I'll tell you what I think is going
to happen, I think what's going to happen
is, people are going to like this, and,
ya know, I don't know, we got a few people
on the editorial board that might frown on
it, in general, the 8-bit stuff
if it's a good game, we like it, but a lot
of times it won't be featured immediately.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: And the main reason is that we're still
worried that the average Google Play subscriber
is not going to understand
the 8-bit motif, they're not going to see
it as an homage. They're going to see it as
something that either looks ugly to
them or reflects badly on the platform. But
I'll tell ya, Tarvaris who does our merchandising
is a huge retro gamer, and--
>>Dan: Yeah, he'll love it, and--
>>Ian: He put together the Indie games.
>>Dan: Yeah, he did.
>>Ian: The Indie games collection last week,
and we're really hoping to do a retro games
collection soon.
>>Dan: Yeah. I very much want to do that,
and this would be a perfect one for that.
I think the only issue with the game is
it can get a little frustrating at times,
because of the jumping.
>>Ian: But that is all about retro games.
>>Dan: It is.
>>Ian: If you're not tearing your hair out
on a retro game then it's not truly a retro
game.
>>Dan: That's actually how I lost all of my
hair.
>>Ian: hmm.
>>Dan: So, umm.
>>Ian: Except for this piece in the back?
>>Dan: Yea, except for this piece in the back.
Um so, uh.
>>Ian: I just touched Dan's hair,
>>Dan: I know.
>>Ian: it felt so weird.
>>Dan: Dirty. All right so, next game we're
looking at, um, let's go to Awesome. Is that
okay?
>>Ian: Sure.
>> Dan: All right.
>>Ian: AWEsum!!!
>> Dan: AWEsum! is a game that is hopefully
going to show up in portrait, yes it did.
>>Ian: NO WAY!! Thank you, Doctor HDMI.
[Dan laughs]
>>Dan: So and to ASUS for putting this really
awesome HDMI set of settings in.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
>>Dan: So, AWEsum.
[Ian sneezes]
Again I'm going to play like this, which looks
even dorkier than, you can go back to camera
two to see just how dorky this
actually looks. But again, this is my goal
of trying to keep the HDMI cord in. MicroAge
HDMI is not meant for the person who
wants to hold their device, jiggle it around,
and play games. It is meant for it sitting
on a table.
>>Ian: So if anybody wants to release a tablet
with a BNC connection, we're all over that.
>>Dan: Yeah. Absolutely.
>>Ray-To: Show up and take my money.
>>Dan: Exactly!
>>Ian: Right.
[Laughter]
>>Dan: So, AWEsum is actually--
>>Ian: By the way, do we have a [unintelligible]
cam today?
>>Ray-To: Sadly we do not.
>>Dan: Argh, that's so sad.
>>Ian: Really, that's too bad.
>>Ray-To: [unintelligible] a BNC cable
>>Dan: So AWEsum! is a game that's uh, I think
it's a game that's great for kids. If I had
a kid, I would totally encourage
them to play this game. The goal is to actually
sum up numbers. In this case the sum is eleven,
you can see it on the top
left hand corner of the screen, and the goal
is to drop these things to get it to eleven,
ninety-nine, none of those will
match up, however, eight and three will, I
can drop that on, and boom, now that goes
away. So it teaches kids basic
arithmetic tables, as well as teaches them,
um, gamer elite skills I guess.
>>Ian: Is it always eleven?
>>Dan: Uh, no. The sum will change. And I
mean, like, at some point you just have to
say I'm going to drop them, cause
there's just nothing I can do, none of these
are going to add up, you know, uh, and you
only have a limited number of those
retries. So there is certain about of luck
involved here. What's even cooler is if you
can get an AWEsum!, where both add
up to eleven.
>>Ian: I really wish you could play the sound
effects. Can I simulate the sound effects?
>>Dan: Yes. You can.
>>together: AWESUM!!!!!!
>>Dan: Twelve, now it's switched to twelve,
and now you'll see whether I can actually
add anything to twelve, which
I can't.
>>Ian: Except the thing is, we don't sound
enough like just laid back California surfer
dudes.
>>Dan: No. You can also rotate these.
>>Ian: Awesome. Bogus, dude.
>>Dan: You can also rotate these like that,
so, Oh shit.
>>Ian: Choke it, dude.
>>Dan: I totally screwed, I could have made
an AWEsum! there, but instead I'm just gonna
drop it, because unfortunately.
All right.
>>Ian: BOGUS!
>>Dan: Thanks. So we're now actually testing
really to see if I can add, which is questionable.
It's actually being nice,
it's giving me things that are allowing me
>>Ian: AWEsum!
>>Dan: That are allowing me to get rid of
the really tall stack there. All right, that'll
work. I still haven't managed to
get a quote unquote AWEsum! yet, but as you
can see, the game is cool and yeah, I think
actually it's going help teach kids
arithmetic, which I really like. There's not
a lot of games out there that would have what
I would consider a mildly
educational component to them. So, uh, yeah
I like it. The game doesn't do anything particularly
wrong. It actually looks
quite good on a tablet. The only thing we
ran into this game, and I never actually managed
to figure out why, was it wasn't
showing up on a Galaxy Nexus.
>>Ian: Right. We were really curious about
that because we looked at the game's listing
and the only thing that they were
filtering on was ETC1, which everything should
have.
>>Dan: Yeah, exactly. So I'm not sure what
was going on with that.
>>Ian: But it doesn't actually show up on
a Galaxy Nexus. I will say this, that filtering
on ETC1 is, um.
>>Dan: It's a, I think there are like I think
maybe two devices that we've ever shipped
that don't support ETC1, but--
>>Ian: Probably not necessary, but you never
know.
>>Dan: Exactly. But if that's really the reason
why it's not showing up, we need to figure
that out. So. that's AWEsum! it
is a really cool game. I definitely want to
nominate it.
>>Ian: The other thing I love about this is
that "awe" in their title is totally in the
D.A.R.E. to keep your kids off
drugs font from the 80's.
>>Dan: Yes, exactly.
>>Ian: And not, can you show that for just
a second there Ray-To?
>>Dan: Yeah. D.A.R.E. It totally is.
>>Ian: I told you it was a very special episode.
>>Dan: Yeah, it needs to have a little period
next to each one of them to it can be some
sort of acronym.
>>Ian: That would be so cool.
>>Dan: That would be so much cooler, yeah.
So um, one thing, one review comment for you
guys. But overall, the game is great
and good job guys! Don't have a lot to say
about that. The final one that we are officially
looking at is Krafteers.
>>Ian: Right, so this is an interesting game.
I didn't know what to expect when I loaded
it up, I wasn't super happy with
the way it looked on phones honestly, um,
but mostly, it wasn't bad, it's just that
on my Galaxy Nexus, all these buttons
were just a little small.
>>Dan: They definitely, I definitely feel
like there is, they're even a little small
on the tablet to be honest. I would
inflate--
>>Ian: Yeah. I would say, if you could inflate
by even twenty percent I think you'd be there.
>>Dan: Yeah, that was definitely my feeling
while I was playing it. Um the game is cool
actually. It's a game in which you
build things and then you fight things with
the things that you built. And if you like
taking lots of objects and
looking all over to find them, and figuring
out how to do things. It's actually really
fun.
>>Ian: It's actually like an easier to discover
version of Minecraft, in a way. I mean, the
crafting and defense mechanic I mean.
>>Dan: yeah.
>>Ian: You know, you'll do things like you'll
pick up a log and make a club out of it, and
you'll club a tree to death, I'm
not actually sure how that works, but, you'll
club down a tree.
>>Dan: Yeah, you'll club down a tree.
>>Ian: And then you'll club its trunk into
planks.
>>Dan: You club its trunk into planks, and
you'll club its planks into sticks.
>>Ian: Exactly.
>>Dan: And you might need sticks and planks
to build something. Sometimes you also get
a little bit of straw, which also may
be useful.
>>Ian: You'll use that to build a fire which
is magical, because I thought you needed wood
for a fire, but apparently
straw is good.
>>Dan: Straw is good enough, yeah.
>>Ian: Then you can also club, oh no, I'm
sorry, you can't club stones, you need to
get a stick.
>>Dan: Flint.
>>Ian: And flint to get a pickaxe.
>>Dan: And the flint you just find..
>>Ian: Oh and a vine from the vine tree.
>>Dan: And a vine from the vine tree, exactly.
>>Ian: And, uh, yeah. I mean you can see it's
something kind of interesting.
>>Dan: We've just proven that we've both played
through the tutorial. Awesome!
[Hands smacking]
>>Dan: So, uh, almost lost my cheese there.
>>Ian: So.
>>Dan: So, uh, oh yeah, so the one thing I
would say, we can't really show you to demonstrate
this, this game does have
music on the live stream though.
>>Ian: Yeah.
>>Dan: Which made me sad,
>>Ian:Babababbabida
>>Dan: No one watches our show, so um yeah.
Fix that. I actually think it's an interesting
game to feature. I'm really
curious what the team would think about it.
>>Ian: I think it's decent. It's not a novel
game, and there are games like this, I will
say it's a little novel in the
sense that I went through the entire tutorial
and it didn't ask me to buy anything. So.
>>Dan: OH!
>>Ian: For this particular genre, not being
nickeled and dimed was actually kind of nice.
>>Dan: Now it did bring up an ad, and I will
say that the one bug was when I clicked on
the ad, it took me into Google Play
to buy something. I clicked back and I never
got the game back. So.
>>Ian: Well, and this is a real problem, it's
very common to mess up the transitions when
your app loses focus, when your
app pauses or stops. You really need to make
sure that you stay where you are and do everything
you can to make it quick to get back in.
I noticed this too, I locked up my phone and
then went back in and it has to reload again,
and it's a real pain. Now on
Honeycomb Above, you can use the API, what's
the API again? To not lose your context?
>>Dan: I am not sure how Tiny Village keeps
showing up here also. It's sometimes when
I randomly click on the screen even
when I don't see an ad, it just randomly goes
there. I haven't figured that one out. I clicked
the full version.
So this doesn't actually pop up full screen
but what I ended up having, when I was in
game, was, there was in game ad of
this and I hit the back key to get out and
then I was stuck forever.
>Ian: OH really?
>>Dan: Yeah. It doesn't happen when you buy
through.
>>Ian: Yeah, you need to watch out for that.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: Yeah, the in app purchase is always
going to pop up as a dialog on the tablet,
yeah.
>>Dan: This is what actually--
>>Ian: I kinda wish it would do that on the
phone too.
>>Dan: Yeah, it's kind of a mixed bag, honestly,
in terms of how good it is. The advantage
of it popping up full screen is
that the system is guaranteed to have enough
memory to actually launch the play store.
>>Ian: Yes but the advantage of it--
>>together: Not popping up full screen is
that it's not going to try to reclaim your
app.
>>Ian: And ninety percent of the time, I mean,
there are a few games that we found where
the play store and your app really
can't co-exist. But in general, the issue
is, if the play store needs more memory, what's
it going to kill first? Is it
going to kill like ten random things that
are taking up a couple megs each?
>>Dan: Actually, the play store doesn't kill
anything, it is what is the android platform
going to try to kill off to free
up more memory.
>>Ian: Right. I'm sorry, I meant the play
store client.
>>Dan: Yeah. When the android platform is
trying to make room for that play store client,
what's it going to kill? Well,
it's gonna say, huh, this is one really big
application that's taking up hundreds of megabytes
of RAM and it's--
>>Ian: It's in the background now---
>>Dan: It's in the background now so I'm going
to kill it off.
>>Ian: Stay tuned on that because we're going
to maybe make some progress there. But for
right now, the lesson to be gleaned
from this if you've got anything that hides
your app, whether it's an ad, or an in app
purchase, some sort of capillary,
or, offer wall, any of those things, if they're
in a different process and they need more
memory, it could result in your
process stopping. You need to be really careful
about testing that sort of thing, and making
sure that your process can
resume in a way that's not going to annoy
the user.
>>Dan: Absolutely. The final thing I actually
wanted to go over was Call of Atlantis which
was another game--
>>Ian: You know, before we hit Call of Atlantis,
I just wanted to mention, we did have a backup
beer, and since I think
we're uh,oh no, I'm done and you're not, which
is good.
>>Dan: It's a thousand IBU's, it's a sipping
beer.
>>Ian: And it's 9.6 percent alcohol, but I
wanted to share this with you because I know
that right after this meeting,
you've got a meeting, with the uh--
>>Dan: Yeah, exactly.
>>Ian: With the Biz Dev people for Call of
Atlantis.
>>Dan: Yeah, exactly.
>>Ian: Which is, by the way, completely coincidental.
>>Dan: Yes, we don't usually, So Call of Atlantis
was really fun. So it was interesting because
Call of Atlantis
came to us and it actually was a game that
was letter boxed. And then I said to the guys,
I'm like look you know this
game looks like it was designed to not run
on anything other than a PC and can you guys
do something about it? And most
developers when I say this are like no it
was not designed and we're not going to touch
it and you know what ever.
>>Ian: Our designers like it that way.
>>Dan: Yeah our designers, but they actually
came and said let's think about it. What they've
done, as you can see here
There's actually stuff, the game originally
ended between the columns on the left and
right hand side of the screen. They
simply extended, they added additional graphics
and they extended it with this little border.
>>Ian: That's, so all that Tuscany marble-y
stuff on the left and the right, was not there,
it was just black before, right?
>>Dan: Exactly, it was just black and it was
funny, because I first looked at it, I said,
well, you know, it’s not
necessarily exactly what I wanted them to
do, but as I, I actually played both versions
of the game side by side, and I
realized as I played this more and more, that
having it fill the full screen and it does
actually fill the full screen
during various parts, like the load screen,
it actually does go full screen there, it
just felt that much better. It was a
real surprise to me. I mean, we've always
said we wanted people to try to use the full
screen, but in this game, even making
a relatively minor change like adding a background
graphic they could extend and not changing
any other part of the game
play made an enormous difference in the experience
to someone who was using it. It really made
it feel like I was playing
something that was meant for my device.
>>Ian: You know, and this brings up an interesting
point, is we've talked a lot about different
screen aspect ratios, and
>>Dan: Oooo, this is good.
>>Ian: Isn't it? this is the barrel aged Bourbon
11, so it's a beer that's been aged in bourbon
barrels.
>>Dan: So another thing I'll tell you, when
we first got this game, all of--
>>Ian: Hang on Hang on--
>>Dan: Oh sorry.
>>Ian: You interrupted me with beer, but you
can always interrupt me with beer, but you
can't interrupt me with other things,
anyway, the point is, we know it can be frustrating
to deal with different aspect ratios, but
there's always some way to do
it that isn't going to just completely suck,
you know?
>>Dan: Yes.
>>Ian: Sometimes you can stretch your game,
some games stretch really well, some games
don't, but you can add a little bit
to either side, sometimes it's just as simple
as hey, you had your scoring area or head,
over the top of the game, and now
there's some area above that that's just blank,
why don't you just move your head up.
>>Dan: Exactly, so so
>>Ian: The one thing you don't want to do
is, and this is what I was getting to, is
try to game the system by defining
compatible screens and making really specific
aspect ratios for each set of screens, do
you know what happened to all the
people who declared on compatible screens
today?
>>Dan: They're not showing up on this device.
>>Ian: That's right. None of them show up
on the Nexus 7, do you know why?
>>Dan: Because we didn't think about it?
>>Ian: Exact--NO, we thought about it! I've
been lured!
[Dan Laughs]
>>Ian: The problem is the Nexus 7 is a geometry
that has never been seen before in android.
It's a seven inch device.
>>Dan: Well it's--
>>Ian: It's twelve eighty by eight hundred.
>>Dan: Most importantly it's a DPI that has
never been seen before.
>>Ian: That's what I meant. It's quote unquote
T.V. DPI.
>>Dan: Yeah. Well, we haven't really named
it, it's two hundred and thirteen DPI's.
>>Ian: Oooo, you said the number.
>>Dan: I know, I know. So, um.
>>Ian: Don't use compatible screens is the
moral of that story.
>>Dan: Yeah, if you can possibly, possibly.
>>Ian: Go back to, I know you're rearing to
talk about Call of Atlantis so.
>>Dan: So, one thing we noticed when we were
first playing the game is that the fonts were
very very low resolution, and
it's interesting because when a font is really
really low resolution, your eye tries to focus
that font, it tries to see,
because it looks blurry, and it just makes
you strain to read all the text as if you're
expecting it to somehow, it tricks
your eyes into trying to get it into focus
when it can't.
>>Ian: The truth is..that's actually just
Dan, he needs bifocals and we haven't told
him yet.
>>Dan:[in a shaky old voice] Thank you Ian.
[Normal voice] Now, back to the game. So we
asked them, we said, look can you do anything
about the font, and they did, and
honestly the game is much much more playable,
and even though the background is still the
equal low resolution, you don't
even really notice. The back for the most
part, the background is a much lower resolution
than the font in the foreground.
But the whole game feels a whole lot more
crisp, and it didn't take that much more space.
And it made a huge difference in
the game play.
>>Ian: And to put it more technically, what
you want to do is watch your high frequency
art, so fonts are always expected to
be high frequency, you can get away with lower
frequency on other pieces of art, like on
your backgrounds for instance, you
can't always get away with it, but in general
you can. But basically you need to look at
your game on different displays,
and ask yourself, especially on the 720P or
even when it releases, the new 1080P tablets.
Look at them and ask yourself,
does your game actually still look good? And
if it doesn't, you might want to start considering,
switching up some art, doing a set
of larger bit maps for instance.
>>Dan: And that's mostly what they did, but
there are some they didn't bother to do, and
for the most part, you don't notice
them. I think the key thing is be strategic,
you don't actually necessarily need to change
every piece of art, in order to
get something feeling like a real tablet app.
All of a sudden, this app, which really felt
very low resolution, very
outdated, all of a sudden feels like a modern
application. So.
>>Ian: It really does. Looks very crisp from
back here. It looks great, and I see what
you mean. The backgrounds are not
necessarily the same resolution, but I think
it's a perfect trade off, what they've done
is they've taken the elements that
are relatively small but high frequency and
put a lot of effort into making those sharp,
and they've taken the elements that
are low frequency, but really really large,
and they've kept those at a lower effective
resolution, which means they use
less memory without actually disturbing the
user experience.
>>Dan: Exactly and that’s, I think that,
Again, one of the reasons I wanted to highlight
this was I really like the trade
offs that they've made. I think they've made
some very smart decisions. I will say the
only thing left that I really really
don't like about this game is their icon.
If we can go, if you can see that icon on
the screen..it just makes me sad
because android icons are not supposed to
be rounded corner things.
>>Ian: Actually...let's talk about all of
these icons, because every single one of them
makes me sad.
>>Dan: They're all bad.
>>Ian: And let's just talk about how each
of them could be better. Dead Trigger...does
not need a rounded rectangle around
it.
>>Dan: No.
>>Ian: No reason. Why not just put, you know,
an outline around the letters?
>>Dan: It would be so cool if they just had
some glowing outline in a back of red, ahhh.
Awesome.
>>Ian: The next one.
>>Dan: Krafteers
>>Ian: Same basic deal, why not just a pickaxe
and flint? Why does it have to have a background?
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: The next one is, well okay, those guys
are little and so's the next one but still..
>>Dan: Tiny Hawk you don't even need to have--
>>Ian: why not just have an Alpha background?
>>Dan: Yeah. Exactly, and AWEsum! definitely
an Alpha background would be awesome. You
only need the three numbers.
>>Ian: 'Cause remember, we know that there
are a lot of guidelines out there, and we
know that a lot of times,
you go with a particular lead skew or a particular,
or maybe it's the device that your boss owns
or whatever,
and they want everything to look like that
particular OS, but remember that android users
bought android for a reason,
they usually love their android device and
they want it to look like android.
>>Dan: And if you look at those icons on the
bottom, which are mostly android system icons,
you can see that they all have
unique shapes. And part of the way people
recognize them is their shapes. You recognize
that the browser is that circle, so
it actually gives the user something else
to clue into.
>>Ian: Right. Now some of these, sometimes
it's really, like for instance YouTube, YouTube's
logo has always looked like
that.
>>Dan: Yes, so it looks like that in the browser.
>>Ian: Right, so even though, if someone were
to come to us with this icon and say does
this look like an android icon,
honestly, we'd say, no, but if it's part of
your branding, if it's part of the way your
brand looks, all right. But
especially when it's obviously not, and Call
of Atlantis is a great example of this. Call
of Atlantis has a brand that's
defined by this circular thing.
>>Dan: And it's got this dragon in the corner.
>>Ian: A circular thing with a dragon in the
corner. Well, the dragon in the corner's just
a badge, right?
>>Dan: Yeah, that's their--
>>Ian: We've got badges, everyone's got badges.
>>Dan: That's their Playrix brand.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: And then the game is actually the circle,
well, it would actually be really cool to
just have it be a circle you
know? And we have full Alpha in these support
in these icons and it can look really really
great.
>>Ian: Right.
>>Dan: It doesn't actually need to have this
thing on the background. So, you know, that's
a general call to developers,
think of, your brand is very very important,
think about how you can make your application
stand out on android by taking
advantage of the fact that you can use funky
shapes.
>>Ian: Yep. Absolutely, and you'll, and the
really really nice thing about this is, instead
of just having a featureless
set of uniform rounded rectangles, your user
will be looking at things where not only the
picture, but also the outline of your icon
will
become a visual cue to them to know where
your application is and what that icon stands
for. So, in general, if you can, and
we realize that sometimes design departments
are tough to convince.
>>Dan: Mmm hmm.
>>Ian: But if you can convince them that they
don't want the rounded rectangle, you can
often get a better, more memorable
icon on android.
>>Dan: Absolutely. So we're almost done for
today.
>>Ian: We are so out of time, we only gave
Ray-To forty-five minutes and we have just
taken fifty-six, you know why?
Because we're awesome.
>>Dan: Rrrrright. Uh, so in any case, definitely
keep nominating stuff to the forum. We really
really appreciate all the
time you guys put in there.
>>Ian: Absolutely.
>>Dan: We really appreciate all the time you
guys put into actually writing games. We've
been so happy, honestly, with a lot
of the games that have come out onto Google
Play Creation League.
>>Ian:It's great, yeah. You know, this year
we have seen so much great stuff on Google
Play, we've still got a few
developers that we really want to bring over,
but in general, the quality is such that,
three years ago we were like, "what
are we going to feature this week?"
[Dan laughs]
>>Ian: and now it's like, "Oh my God, how
are we, what are we going to reject because
they're all so good?"
>>Dan: Yeah. It's great to see everyone taking
to the platform, and to me, I think having
a Nexus 7 as a reference device
for people to play off is great. What's awesome
is, this a a hundred ninety-nine dollar device
in the U.S. It's a low end
device!
>>Ian: It's a hundred and ninety-nine dollars,
and it's slightly more capable than an Xbox
one.
>>Dan: It's kind of amazing.
>>Ian: Almost. I mean Modulo's, some custom
software, it's in the league of the ASUS Transformer
Prime, which has been our
top performing go to device for a long time,
and it's only two hundred bucks.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: Which just blows my mind, now, I would
say that I'm gonna buy one for my wife, but
if I bought one for my wife,
she'd be pissed because I just spent two hundred
bucks. I need to find a way to get it for
free.[Dan laughs] and then
she'll, so I think what I'm going to do get
one for myself for free and then buy one,
and give her the one that was free,
and say it was free.
>>Dan: Right, exactly. So.
>> Ian: My wife's like that. Anyway, but yeah
so--
>>Dan: You know, she doesn't watch this program,
fortunately.
>>Ian: Nah, sometimes she does actually, but,
the other thing that the Tegra 3 platform
I don't want to massively pimp the
Tegra 3 platform, it has its good side and
it has its bad side. You know, it's a platform.
But, you may have noticed that
some companies are betting heavily on it in
the gaming space. Well, here's a chance to
get a Dev Kit really cheap.
>>Dan: Exactly.
>>Ian: I don't know why we're pimping this
so heavily, because like nobody's going to
pay us for doing that.
>>Dan: I know, we're gonna get a call from
the guys in Dev and they're going to be like,
"Thank you, we love you all."
>>Ian: It's just one of those things where
we're, like, you know, phones come out and
sometimes we're like super happy like
oh yeah, this is super great, but, let me
speak frankly for a moment.
>>Dan: Is this different than the rest of
the show? [laughs]
>>Ian: In the history of android, a lot of
times something will come out and we're like,
you know, that's awesome, but I can
go to the store and get something, a competing
product, that's just as good for either a
lower price, or maybe the same
price but maybe objectively, it's slightly
better in some ways, and this changes all
of that. This is the first product that
we've shipped, where it's competitive on price,
and performance and pretty much everything
else and we've had a lot of fun
playing with it. We've had development devices
in for about two months now, been carrying
them with us, we've been sharing
them with developers in our lab, and every
time I pick one up I'm like, wow, I'm really
happy that we're shipping this
device.
>>Dan: Yeah. It's a warm and fuzzy feeling
to be proud of something your shipping like
this, and I'll be from a developer's
perspective, the other thing that's great
about it is that its video performance tools,
work out of the box on this device.
>>Ian: NO WAY!!
>>Dan: Yes, which is awesome.
>>Ian: NO WAY! That's so awesome.
>>Dan: Yeah.
>>Ian: So basically, I was on the Xbox 360
launch team, and I think that since then,
I think this is the first device that
I've been just as excited about.
>>Dan: Awesome.
>>Ian: Well maybe not quite as excited but
you went out into the desert for the Xbox
360.
>>Dan: I did, I was there freezing in the
desert with everyone else. It was awesome.
[hands smack]
>>Ian: Nice.
>>Dan: It was a good thing that they distributed
sweatshirts to us. So in any case, that's
it for today's Friday Game
Review. Again, continue putting cool stuff
on the Moderator, we're going to continue
to mix it up a little, I would actually
love to show you guys those performance analysis
tools, and maybe we'll run a game through
the wringer.
>>Ian: Let us know. You can give us feedback
on our Google Plus page and you can give us
feedback on YouTube, but we
probably won't read it because let's face
it, YouTube commenters? come on!
[Laughter]
>>Ian: but in general we want to know what
you think and we also want to know what you
want to see. Would you like to see
more technical info? Because that's kind of
our job, we're engineers. Would you like to
see more game reviews? We can do
that too. We are massive gamers. What's most
interesting to you? Anyway, let's sign off
for now. Next week, we'll be back
with another beer and another set of games.
Love you all, see you later.